hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen jetzt zu einer setup
touren zwar habe ich ja irgendwann mal
in einem video vor zwei wochen oder so
gefragt jetzt geht gerade einfach die
sonne einfach weg es ist so ein schönes
wetter ist es richtig blauer himmel
sonne und jetzt verschwindet ihr einfach
davor zwei wochen mal in einem video
gefragt was ich von seiner set up zu
erhalten würde weil ich mir neue
tastatur neue beleuchtung neues
mischpult und so weiter gekauft habe und
9 bildschirm und so weiter und so fort
habe ich euch mal gefragt was er von
seiner neuen setup equipment erhalten
würde und die meisten meilen so kann es
eigentlich mal machen deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht ich mach das jetzt einfach
mal und das ist einfach der grund warum
wir gerade nur meine fresse sich um kein
spiel im hintergrund oder so erst mal so
sieht es aus wenn ich quasi am pc sitzt
dann habe ich hier quasi so hier ist
mein kopf dann habe ich hier so die
mauer ist habe ich dann meine linke hand
und hier mache ich dann irgendwas ihr
seht schon ja das ist apple und ja das
ist ein imac viele meinten
aber etwas anderer meinung und zwar ist
dass dieser neue imac retina 5k mit ein
ganz guter ausstattung und es läuft
zumindest alles super also ich kann
perfekt aufnehmen wird es ja minecraft
leben mit shader geht alles klar
internet also damit davon ist er
natürlich nicht abhängig aber läuft auch
alles super und ich kann unter apple
einfach besser arbeit noch für die in
ihren sound dieser grafik ich weiß nicht
ob ich habe grade ja ich hab ja spotify
immer offen diese grafik ist einfach so
unfassbar toll sieht man jetzt gerade
nicht so gut weil das sich so ein
bisschen reflektiert und da auch ein
bisschen staub drauf ist weil ich nicht
so toll geputzt habe aber ich weiß ja
wenn man sehen kann man das ist halt 5k
display und freunde das machte spaß
damit zu arbeiten also das ist schon mal
so meinen pc ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
den in der beschreibung packen kann dann
habe ich einfach mal apple inc oder so
am rhein das ist halt der imac retina 5
k
27 zoll mit 16 gigabyte ram und
was hat der für eine grafikkarte wo ich
kann mal kurz hier oben kann ich da mal
eben kurz auf über diesen mac klicken
dann da da könnt ihr euch das anschauen
was der so für werther ich weiß es gibt
pcs die haben 230 gigabyte ram und die
haben ideal grafikkarte mit dem und ein
prozessor mit diesem und alles viel
bessere werte aber ich kann einfach mit
apple ich arbeite damit seit 10.000
millionen jahren und ich komme damit
besser klar und von mir aus hätte mich
dafür aber ich komme einfach mit apple
besser da klar also das ist ja eine
geschmackssache also calado das ist auf
jeden fall bald wird sie dann kommen wir
hier auch schon zu meinem micro einfach
weil es immer so viele fragen in den
kommentaren habe ich das jetzt ja auch
immer in der beschreibung stehen das ist
das rote nt 1a und das nutze ich seitdem
ich mit youtube angefangen habe ich habe
glaube ich damals mal irgendwann ein
headset mikrofon benutzt aber das war
nicht so toll und das ist halt ein gros
membran mikrofon mono das heißt wenn ihr
in dieser seite rein spricht kommt der
ton scheiße an und hier kommt er gut an
quasi in kurzfassung dann habe ich hier
diese spinne vor dass ich habe einfach
sonst app gekauft damals also alles
dabei da war dass dabei dann dieser
dieser pop schutz hier vorne also die
spinne pop schutz mikrofon dann xlr
kabel dabei und auch ein gelenk kam und
dieser gelenkarm ist eigentlich von
millennium aber den kann man ihnen nicht
mehr kaufen ich bin mit dem mega
zufrieden habe ich hier angebracht
direkt über der marshall box hier und
ich habe euch aber mal eine beschreibung
gepackt ich mir wahrscheinlich bald
holen werde das ist eine rote ps 1a
heißt er meine ich habe danach gerät psa
1 also das ist so ein sonnen gelenkarm
einfach der ist quasi genauso also
könnte dann das mikrofon einfach so ein
bisschen rum schwenk und ich hatte halt
damals erst und stativ einfach aber das
war ein bisschen sperrig und hiermit
kann ich jetzt einfach eigentlich sie
das hier hin oder hierhin das ist
einfach viel viel besser also der
gelenkarm ist eigentlich von millennium
aber ich habe euch einen von rot eine
beschreibung gepackt weil der einfach
nicht mehr geht weil der mir nicht mehr
gebaut wird oder so und da geht halt das
xlr kabel hier raus die hinter meinem pc
her und kommt dann
ein bisschen staubig ist es tut mir leid
weil ich hier nicht geputzt habe ich
auch gestern bad geputzt dann geht das
xlr kabel hier vorne rein dann habe ich
nämlich ihr schon das kann ich euch
jetzt schon mal zeigen dass
dbx
286 es mike trient prozessor also die
hat beispielsweise ein kompressor 3ds
was er noch alles in den henson expander
gate ganze sache ist einfach einmalig
trient das haben mir freaks lp und komme
glaube ich empfohlen und damit bin ich
mega zufrieden ich muss die einstellung
zwar immer noch ein bisschen optimieren
aber das wird schon noch und da geht das
ganze auf jeden fall erstmal rein da
wird der kompressor oder drauf gepackt
und so weiter einmal dass die stimme
wenn ich schreie und wendig leise rede
dass sie quasi auf einer höhe ist dann
geht das ganze hier über klinke wieder
raus und über xlr dann hier noch mal in
mein behringer 6002 weil ich irgendwie
finde dass wenn das doppelt durch mich
politik hört sich das besser an und da
geht das hier über links rechts links
wieder hier in den computer da mag einen
mikrofoneingang hat geht er einfach über
usb ding in großbeeren und das passt
doch alles super dass ich auch
eigentlich ganz passabel an also kurz
was man nochmal bezüglich der ganzen
mikrofon aufnahme stimmen aufnahme sache
oder nt 1a im paket gekauft mit spindel
pop schutz et cetera das ist ein
millenium griff an den gibt's aber nicht
mehr deswegen habe ich euch die das rote
ps1 eine beschreibung gepackt dann geht
das überall mehrere xlr kabel und
klinkenkabel hier in das die wx handy
halt's maul in das dbx 286 es rein wo
das ganze ein kompressor bekommt ds und
so weiter und dann nochmal über das
behringer und dann in den 1 dann habe
ich hier den ton mit dem ich immer meine
videos aufnehmen kann ich zeige euch
einfach mal eindruck haben also den
werde ich euch nicht in beschreibungen
fall liegt glaube ich bin einfach mega
zufrieden damit dass ist der canon mg
42 50 also darf fragen sich auch mal
einige höhe was ist das hier um steht
diesmal ein drucker haben wir hier schon
meine erste videoleuchte die kann ich
auch mal eben hier an machen habe ich
mich hier sein kabel einfach so sagt das
ist meine erste videoleuchte die kommen
quasi von links und von rechts haben wir
das hier dazu komme ich gleich noch mal
das ist nicht das was ich mir neu
gekauft habe und
darin bin ich mega zufrieden aber das
ist auf jeden fall erstmal eine ganz
normale videoleuchte also die hat glaube
ich sogar dies 29 euro aus japan also da
könnt ihr euch irgendeine kaufen einfach
das ist das ist einfach einfach nur
licht was quasi von links kommt übrigens
falls ihr euch fragt wo diese ganzen
kabel hingehen die ich euch quasi von
vorne gerade von der softbox oder so
gezeigt habe ich habe ich unter meinem
schreibtisch sonne ganz viele leisten wo
das ganze hingeht und das coole ist ich
habe quasi auf den leisten die könnt ihr
auch einfach überall kaufen die
musikrichtungen verlinken habe ich da so
kleine schalter stehen das heißt wenn
ich nur mal die pc vom strom ausschalten
möchte kann ich da einfach so einen
kleinen schalter drücken da hab ich halt
mehrere drauf das wusste ich vorher noch
gar nicht dachte es gibt noch
steckerleisten wo man das komplett alles
ausschalten und anschalten kann aber so
finde ich das auf jeden fall ganz cool
also da unten kommt quasi meinen ist
meine stromquelle sage ich mal dann
machen wir jetzt mal weiter mit der
anderen video beleuchtung und zwar mit
dieser kleinen hier das ist die jung nun
rupps i lon jung genug y n 300 das ist
eine videoleuchte die kann man bei
amazon kaufen und da muss man sich dann
halt auch noch ein kleines stativ dazu
kaufen da kann ich auch hier offen
machen und dann kann ich das quasi
einfach ein bisschen höher schieben aber
ich lass das jetzt sogar dass uns runter
krachen würde und das ding auch gerade
einfach an ist das hat eigentlich hat
das jesus schieferplatten also wie kann
man da vorschieben und ihr seht schon da
sind also kleine lichter und da steht
man dann quasi einfach davor und da gibt
es dann das sind dann andere sachen wie
nicht nur in weiß sondern auch in blau
in orange und schwarz und so weiter
einfach wenn man verschiedene quellen
verschiedene lichtstärke bzw die
lichtfarben haben möchten die so sepia
oder er so dunkel damit war ich aber
nicht so ganz zufrieden das licht was
dann nämlich rauskamen wenn ich nur
diese platte hier drin hätte das war mir
so ein bisschen zu kalt deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier einfach noch sonst tut
einfach so drüber geklickt sogar das
provisorisch einfach mit tesafilm und
jetzt ist das licht nämlich genau die
passende stärke die ich möchte weil
hiermit war das so richtig grell und
somit wird es jetzt ein bisschen gedimmt
und das coole daran ist ich kann während
der aufnahme habe ich hier so eine
fernbedienung und dann kann ich ja
einfach mal sagen ja du kannst das ganze
ja mal ein bisschen heller machen oder
auch ja macht das ganze doch mal ein
bisschen dunkler oder mama diesmal mal
da und da kann ich da auch quasi
verschiedene kameras einfach auswählen
also ich kann mit recht sagen verguckt
wie den jackmann bedingtes theoretisch
sagen hey ich habe keinen es oder ich
habe zwei elf- oder ich habe nie korn
oder kilometer sein scheinen scanner das
alles bedeutet habe ich kann auf jeden
fall ihr sagen oft und blabla und so
weiter und so fort das ist eigentlich
ganz nice was ich damals so alles machen
kann aber was mich da ein bisschen
aufgeregt bz was eigentlich auch gut ist
das ganze ding hat ein akku das heißt
ich muss den akku abnehmen wenn er leer
ist das hält irgendwie für zwei stunden
oder so dann packe ich dann einfach hier
rein und in der steckdose dann kann ich
das ganze halt aufladen das ist
einerseits natürlich scheiße das ist
teilweise eine aufnahme einfach mal kann
sein das ist einfach so ausgeht aber für
irgendwelche aufnahmen wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mich auf meine couch
setzte und lego minecraft aufgenommen
habe konnte ich die quasi einfach so
mitnehmen ohne irgendeine steckdose zu
suchen oder so also das ist ganz neues
findet ihr auch ein weg in der
beschreibung jung-moo y 300 und falls
ihr euch bestellt wundert euch nicht die
ganzen anleitungen sind in japanische
hier vorne ist einfach mal eine ps4
falls euch gefragt habe was ihr neben
steht ps4 aufkleber sorry gaal
jedenfalls einfach zwei controller ps4
muss ich nicht viel zu sagen jeder kennt
die bs spiel und das jetzt auch relativ
kräftig an haben wir hier einen zweiten
bildschirm den seht ihr schon das war
mir sehr wichtig dass ich mir dann neuen
kauf zum umziehen und zwar durch damals
meinem zimmer hatte ich einen fernseher
und halt mein pc aber jetzt habe ich ja
keinen fernseher mehr deswegen habe ich
mir halt diesen asus vg 27 8 ha gekauft
den namen weiß ich noch ganz genau und
zwar weil das der einzige geile
bildschirm mit guter bewertung in 27
zoll meine ich dr und jetzt nicht mehr
nicht dann haltet euch fest weil es
eigentlich relativ normal für ein
bildschirm ist aber das war der einzige
die nicht gewonnen habt ihr zwei
hdmi-anschlüsse hatte ich erzähle euch
jetzt mal die ganze story und zwar hatte
ich halt damals war es mal ein pc wo ich
die ganzen pc sachen gemacht habe und
meinen fernseher wohl drauf ich gezockt
habe aber da ich in meiner wohnung
einfach keinen fernseher brauche weil
ich eine aktion die fernsehen gucke und
alles mögliche wie zirkus halligalli
oder fußball kann ich auch ein live
stream schauen und serien bei netflix
und so weit habe ich mir gedacht ich
brauche ich brauchen monitor den ich
einerseits als zweiter monitor für den
imac benutzen kann aber auch als quasi
quelle als bildquelle für meine
playstation wenn freunde dar und wird
zocken wollen deswegen hab ich ein
monitor gesucht der einerseits zwei
hdmi-anschlüsse hatte also nimm einen
ist quasi der pc drin und dann kann ich
hier einfach umschalten bei diesen ein
knopf und dann wird die playstation
daran aktiviert und dann habe ich noch
ein gesucht der einen lautsprecher hat
und er hat einen lautsprecher ist 27
zoll hat eine gute grafik eine gute
bewertung und hat zwei hdmi-anschlüsse
deswegen bin ich mit dem mega zufrieden
mit dem von von asus acer skandal wie
das gesprochen wird der heißt asus v2
sie macht h ist auch eine beschreibung
kann ich jedem nur empfehlen diesen
monitor ich bekomme dafür übrigens
nichts und würde die irgendwo sehen
übrigens voll viele sagen du machst du
preez werden liegen produkt vorstellt
freunde wenn ich ein product placement
mache dann steht das oder beschreibungen
oder irgendwo weil man das angeben muss
also ich hinterher versteht man die jagd
ist einfach nur weil ich damit zufrieden
mit den sachen ihr müsst euch den scheiß
nicht kaufen aber ich bin damit
zufrieden dann kommen jetzt auch zur
schon zu den letzten sachen meine maus
ist die razer mamba die hat bei amazon
eine totale scheiß bewertung aber ich
bin damit zufrieden also ich nutze die
mittlerweile zeit ihr seht doch schon da
sind so mega viele staub sache
mittlerweile drin ich muss ja endlich
mal saubermachen ich nutze ich schon
seit 23 jahren oder so ich weiß ja jetzt
schon so lange draußen ist auf jeden
fall seitdem ich hier wohne auf jeden
fall schon und schon noch länger das ist
eigentlich eine eine kabellose maus aber
ich nutze die man mit kabel weil keine
ahnung und damit bin ich eigentlich ganz
zufrieden weil das eigentlich einfach
mit der maus ist wo ich mich quasi
einfach so meine hand drauf legen kann
komplett ich find die anderen heute sind
alle so komisch wäre ich also mit dass
die razer mamba dann hab ich mir eine
neue tastatur gekauft das ist die roccat
ok glaub ich hatte vorher die isku aber
die ist mir einfach kaputt gegangen hat
einfach ein paar tasten aufgehört zu
funktionieren
deswegen habe ich mir dann gedacht ich
hole mal die riders im cache bin ich
auch ganz gut mit zufrieden ist eine
mechanische tastatur und die hört man
auch teilweise meinen aufnahmen weil
mein mikrofon hat quasi mal hier ist und
meint an tastatur direkt hier und
deswegen hört man das direkt weil die
ist auch relativ laut wenn ich immer so
das ist schon relativ der mac hat gerade
hier so ein bisschen übrigens was auch
ganz cooles an magna
total synchronisiert einfach mit meinem
handy das heißt wenn ich beispielsweise
irgendwelche in welche sachen habe die
gleich anstehen oder so dann informierte
mich da die elektro wunders könnte so
eine cloud synchronisation quasi nie
aufbauen müssen heute haben wir das
gerät das ich möchte nicht sagen kauft
euch ein apple weil ich bekomme noch für
nix wenn ich ein produkt mit apple hätte
dann würde ich glaube ich kein youtube
beharren aber ich bin damit zufrieden
aber ich möchte einfach nicht dass
freunde sagen einfach haye der total
scheiße die handy also das ist die
tastatur das ist ein mechanisches im klo
und die letzte sache ich meine webcam wo
er den tape kittelmann drittel der
webcam ist die logitech 10 920 damit bin
ich eigentlich mega zufrieden nur wenn
ihr euch die also dies vom bild nahezu
geiler als die kennen
eos 600d die ich damals mal hatte uns
kostet die 70 jahre oder so nur sage ich
mal schon vier für eine webcam aber die
hat eine mega geile qualität ist über
usb angeschlossen die streiche die hier
das interview das einzige problem bei
der sache ist wenn man damit quasi so
videoaufnahmen macht dann wird das nach
der zeit als synchron also man muss die
in punkt mv abspeichern das ist ein
kleiner insidertipp der mir von spiele
trend gegeben wurde also das ist meine
webcam und das war es dann auch
eigentlich schon oder dass ich meine das
war alles meinen meinem monitor mein
normales mischpult mein kompressor
mischpult meine tastatur eine maus meine
webcam eine jungkuh video leichte rechts
meine ganz normale videoleuchte links
meine ja einfach so eine lampe ich habe
ich halt noch stehen mein telefon und
mal ein drucker meilen rohde endlich
eins am mikrofon mikrofonarm x pc und
das war total freuen ich hoffe ich
konnte euch damit irgendwie weiterhelfen
also viele hatten ja gefragt sieht
probleme als mit meinem mischpult dich
das gelöst habe und als meine tastatur
kaputt war und so weiter ich hab mal ein
paar neue sachen gekauft weil ich finde
diese ganze paket wenn ich mich dann
dahinter schneiden muss und dann muss
ich zurück sein und blabla ich einfach
keinen bock drauf weil ich eh neue
sachen braucht und so ein bisschen
geschwächelt habe mein equipment hatte
ich mir dann einfach ein bisschen neue
sachen geholt die single investiert und
das habe ich jetzt einfach mal gezeigt
findet links in der beschreibung ich
würde mich über eine bewertung